SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
Firebase is about helping
you build better apps and
grow successful businesses.
And with that, the main
goal here-- the main point
here is that better
apps are actually
associated with more
successful businesses.
And why is that?
Why is building stable,
higher-quality apps
really related to building
better and more successful
businesses?
To answer this question,
we looked at data
from Google Play.
And specifically, we classified
all the one-star reviews
on Google Play on what are
users complaining about?
What didn't they
like about this app
that they gave it
a one-star review?
And we realized that more than
50% of these one-star reviews
are just stability issues.
These are not functional
issues, these are not
missing features in the
app, but these are just
basically bugs and crashes
happening in the app
and affecting the ratings.
So with that in mind,
the quality of the app
is one of the most important
drivers in the user's retention
and engagement.
And it can also affect your
revenues significantly.
So Firebase is trying
to help developers
build more successful
and better apps.
But it seems that
developers themselves--
they are not really focusing
on bugs and crashes sometimes.
And the reason--
basically, developers
are not focused on closing
these bugs and crashes.
And why aren't they doing that?
If you look at the
mobile ecosystem today,
there's a lot of variations
in devices, platforms, network
conditions, locations, locales.
So many things that might
go wrong with the apps.
So it's really difficult
to actually test
against all these things
before using the apps.
And this is where
Firebase app quality
tools are trying to help.
So we looked at our
practices inside Google,
and we've been building
apps for a really long time.
And we realized that the key to
building higher-quality apps is
a combination of two things--
being proactive, which means
try to prevent the issues
before they happen
in the first place.
And being reactive, so as
soon as a new crash starts
happening, you want to go ahead
and investigate it, and fix it
in a timely manner.
And with being
proactive in mind,
the tools that
Firebase app quality
provides to help with that--
the first one is
Firebase Test Lab.
So Firebase Test Lab
tries to provide you
with a testing solution
that helps you emulate
the actual production
environment that your user are
currently using your apps on.
So for example,
we give you access
to physical devices,
actual phones running
in our data sensors.
And you can, with one
click, run your test
on Samsung and Motorala,
running Android Jelly Bean
and KitKat in two different
orientations, five
different languages.
And with one click, you
launch all these tests
and basically try
all these parameters,
and it makes sure that your
app is working across all
these different parameters.
The second part about
the infrastructure
is the virtual devices.
So besides the actual physical
devices in out data centers,
we have an option
for virtual devices.
These are full Android versions
running on a virtual machine.
So you can imagine
the amount of scaling
you can do with these devices.
You can launch hundreds
or thousands of tests
at the same time.
So one test that would
take five, six hours to run
can actually finish in just a
matter of a couple of minutes.
This is how much you can
scale with virtual devices.
And since we launched
at Google I/O this year,
our primary focus was to
increase the number of devices
that we have in the catalog.
And since Google
I/O, we have actually
doubled the number of physical
devices in our catalog.
But more importantly, we
worked very, very closely
with the Android team on the
next generation of Android--
the NMR1.
And moving forward,
every new Android release
is going to have corresponding
devices on Firebase Test
Lab ready for use so that you
don't have to install these two
images on your own devices.
You can use them
directly on the Cloud.
We have also listened
to users' feedback.
The number one piece of feedback
we've got since Google I/O
after we released the product
is that developers want
to try that product before
they actually commit,
and enter their credit
card, and start using it.
And as of last month, we
have launched a free tier
for Firebase Test Lab.
Which means that without
having to enter any credit card
information, you can
get up to 15 tests--
10 tests on virtual devices,
5 tests on physical devices,
every single day for free.
And this will help
you evaluate Test Lab
and make sure it fits
within your business needs
before you can actually commit,
or you can just basically use
the free tier forever.
Now, one of the things
I really, really
like about Firebase Test Lab
is how well it integrates
with your existing workload.
We have a web
interface where you
can, with a matter of a couple
of clicks, uploading your APK,
selecting some devices,
you can run your test
on hundreds of device
configurations.
We also have the integration
with Android Studio.
So from within your own
development environment,
when you're actually
writing your code,
you can say, OK, I'm
implementing a new UI feature.
I want to make sure that
this UI feature works
well across different devices,
different form factors,
and with one click, from
within Android Studio,
you can launch your test
on hundreds of devices.
And then my personal
favorite here
is actually the
command line interface.
And the reason it's
my personal favorite
is that it allows you
to run these tests
from continuous
integration environments.
So how many of you here know
what continuous integration
environments are
and have used them?
Jenkins.
Circle.
Travis.
Very few, which is fine.
But I'm hoping by
the end of today,
everyone here will at
least give it a try
and try running their tests
on continuous integration.
What continuous
integration helps
you do is that for every
change you add to your code,
you can build your
app to make sure
that this change didn't break
any of your existing code.
And you can run your
tests on as many devices
as you want on
Firebase Test Lab.
So you can make sure that
existing features in your app
actually didn't break.
Now, many of you
will be thinking,
now I have to go back and learn
a new programming language,
and start writing a
lot of test script,
and setting up too
many different things.
And the answer is actually no,
because of two great features
that I really, really like
about Firebase Test Lab.
The first one is what
we call the Robo test.
This is an intelligent
app crawler
that launches your
application and tries
to navigate through it.
So clicking on Menu,
swiping through screens
and scrolling through the
app, clicking on buttons.
And the idea here is we want to
expose either crashes so we can
tell you, here's a
crash in your app,
and here's the path
leading to the crash.
Or we want to expose
layout inconsistencies
between different screenshots
on different devices.
And this is what the Robo
test allows you to do.
We've been working really,
really hard in improving
the coverage of the crawler.
And if you look
here, actually, this
is the Google I/O 2016 app.
This app actually runs
behind the login screen.
And the Robo still managed
to create an account,
and login through
the app, and navigate
the app until it was able
to find a crash in the app.
This is an actual [INAUDIBLE].
This is not even some
demo that we put.
We actually crawled the
Google I/O 2016 app,
and we were able to find the
crash without the user having
to write a single line of code.
All they really needed
is just the APK.
The second feature I'm
really, really excited
about is an integration we've
done with Android Studio
to allow you to create test
scripts by just using your app.
And I'm going to demo
this in a little bit.
But this is called
the Espresso Test
Recorder in Android Studio.
Has anyone heard of it?
No, OK.
You're going to
see it right now.
And there's going to be no
excuse to not create some test
cases from now on.
So the Espresso Test Recorder
captures all the interactions
you are doing with
your screen and allow
you to expose all
these interactions
into a fully reusable
instrumentation test
that you can then
run every time you
change your code in
your app and make sure
that your app is functional.
So to recap, Firebase Test Lab
gives you access to devices,
gives you access
to infrastructure,
integrates really, really well
with your existing workflow,
and it is really, really
easy to get started.
You don't need a credit card.
You don't even need test cases.
All you need is your app.
We've been working very
closely with our partners
since our launch at
Google I/O. And these
are some of our partners.
This is [INAUDIBLE],
it's a shopping company.
And they really like the
fact that Firebase Test Lab
integrated with their
existing workflow
and allowed them to launch
their tests directly
from within Android Studio.
So with that in
mind, this is what
I have about being
proactive, which
means we try to prevent
as many bugs as possible
before releasing the
app to production.
Now, the next part is
well, after I actually
release my app to
production, I want
to make sure that
if there's anything
I've missed-- if
there's anything
that my QA team has missed,
I want to go back and fix it
right away.
But more importantly, I want
to know about it right away.
And this is where Firebase
Crash Reporting comes into play.
Firebase Crash Reporting
collects all the crashes
that happen in
production and gives you
all the information you need
to investigate these crashes
and go back and fix your app.
It is cross-platform,
which means
it works on Android and iOS
on both Objective-C and Swift.
Super easy to install.
All you really need to
get it starting on Android
is just one line in
your [INAUDIBLE] config.
And on iOS, you need
to install [INAUDIBLE].
And that's it--
you're up and running.
Now, the part that I really like
about Firebase Crash Reporting
is that as we mentioned
earlier, app quality is really
important for your business.
And one of the most
important parts about it
is that it helps you understand
the impact of that crash
and how much it impacts
and affects your users.
So you can triage your crashes
and focus on what matters most
and what is most
important for your users.
And another part
where it integrates
with Firebase Analytics,
which means that
from within the crash,
you can actually
create cohorts and measure
the effect of a crash
on the retention of your
users, and potentially
on your revenue.
We've been working closely with
our developers and our users
for Firebase Crash Reporting.
And one of the features that
they really, really, like
is the Firebase Crash
Reporting console.
The reason they like it
is that it's actionable.
It gives you the trends
of crashes over time
and also clusters
these crashes for you,
so you can look at
a specific cluster
and triage it, make sure
it's the most important thing
to focus on at the moment.
And then once you
triage-- once you
start focusing on
a certain cluster,
it provides you with
all the information
you need to actually
investigate that crash
and fix it and go back, get
your app to a more stable state.
So as I mentioned,
Firebase Crash Reporting
was announced at
Google I/O this year,
and it was a beta product.
We've worked really hard.
We've collaborated with
our developers community.
We've listened to a ton of
feedback from our developers.
And as of last
month, this project
is no longer a beta product.
So thanks so much for our
developer community for all
the feedback they've given us.
And we're looking
forward to working
with more and more developers
and hearing more feedback
in order to make our
products a lot better.
So while we were
exiting beta, we
focused on a number of features
that our developers really
wanted in [INAUDIBLE].
And they're essential for a
good crash reporting module.
The first one is
actually alerts.
So many of you want
to know of a new crash
or a new cluster of crashes
that is happening right away.
And with alerts, we actually
send you email notifications.
You can also do some
customizations to enable it
on Slack, or
HipChat, or whatever
tool you're using for alerting.
So that's a very
important feature.
And thanks to our
developer community
for making sure that we
focus on the right things.
And we've launched this already
with our [INAUDIBLE] beta
[INAUDIBLE].
The second issue is we're
giving you the ability
to close a certain issue.
So once you're done, once
you've fixed a certain crash,
you can go back to the
console and close it.
And make sure it doesn't
affect any of your trends,
as we mentioned
earlier, in the console.
And then finally, we have been
providing analytics integration
out the box.
So without having
to do anything,
we give you all the analytics
logs leading up to a crash.
So you can look at these
events and triage them.
And also, they can help you
investigate your crashes
and fix your app.
With that in mind, that's why I
have also about being reactive.
So Firebase Crash
Reporting helps you
once a new issue happens,
helps you go back
and understand what's
going on, fix that issue.
Gives you all the
necessary information,
alerts you about the
issue, and then you
can relatively fix your app.
So we talked about being
proactive with Firebase Test
Lab.
And we talked about it being
reactive with Firebase crash
reporting.
Now let's actually
switch to a demo.
But before I talk
about the demo,
let me try to describe
the scenario that
is leading up to the demo.
And it's a scenario that happens
to us developers all the time.
We wake up one morning with
a new alert or a notification
about a crash that is
occurring in one of our apps.
The first thing we want
to do is understand
the effect of that crash.
Is that something we need to
focus on and drop everything
and work on right away?
Or is that something
that can wait
for the next release of our
app, and we can just wait a week
or so until we push
the fix for it?
Once we understand the
impact of the crash
and the effect of
the crash, and then
decide that it's something
we want to work on,
we start by trying to
reproduce that crash.
We try to find or emulate the
exact environment leading up
to that crash based on
all the data that we
can gather about that crash.
And once we do that and
reproduce that crash,
we're going to go to our code
and start debugging that crash.
So we want to look at
the line in the code,
we want to set up
our environment
and start developing and
then debug that crash
until we can actually fix it.
Once we have a fix, we
want to release that app
with the fix to our users.
But more importantly,
what we're goon to do
is that we want to avoid that
crash ever happening again.
And this is something
that we're going
to talk about today as well.
With that, I'll transition
to the demo now.
So this is the demo,
and the first thing
I have here is a screenshot of
one of the emails that Firebase
Crash Reporting provides you,
which alerts you of a new crash
cluster happening in your app.
So this is an
example of an email,
and then it's telling you hey,
there's a new fatal cluster
showing up in one of
your apps, and you
should go ahead investigate it.
So you want to click
here on View Details.
Once you do that, it takes
you to the Firebase console.
And this is the page that is
describing this exact crash.
As you can see here,
there's information
about the versional path.
So it's on version 55.
It happened 10 times
on 10 different users.
And it's happening on API levels
22, 23, 24 and other, others
being 25.
It also shows you
the devices where
this crash has happened on.
And then it shows you some
stat traces and snapshots
about this crash.
So we try to gather
as much information,
whether it's stat
traces, whether it's
performance data of the
device, whether it's
some device information,
error data, user data.
And then if you
scroll even further,
you can look here at
the analytic event.
These are analytics events
provided to you out of the box
that is every event
leading up to a crash.
So you can see here,
select content.
Level start.
Level up.
Level complete.
[INAUDIBLE] core.
And everything about that
crash until a cool new feature
was clicked, and then the
fatal crash started showing up.
So we can also look at
different snapshots.
And it seems that stat trace
is pretty consistent here.
The message on the
stat trace tells us
that this is a
crash that happens
on API levels more than 21.
So it seems that
there's a pattern here
that only occurs on API levels
more than 21, 22, or above.
So I don't have a
device, actually,
that is more than API level 21.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to try to run a test on
Firebase Test Lab on one
of the devices that is
more than 21 and then see,
how can I get out of that test?
So I'm going to go to the
Firebase console here.
And what I'm going to do is
this is the Firebase console.
I'm going to click on Test Lab.
And then hit Run a Test.
And I'm going to try
to write a Robo test.
And again, the Robo
test is the app crawler
that we talked about earlier.
And to run a Robo test, you
need nothing but your app.
So I'm going to
try that right now.
As you can see,
nothing but my APK.
I'm just going to
upload my APK here.
Which, wow-- it
worked very quickly.
And then you click continue.
And then that's it.
You can select now which
devices at which API levels.
So what I'm going to do is
I don't care about these.
I only care about 22 and above.
And try 22 and 23.
Maybe at 24 and 25.
On landscape and portrait.
And then I'm going
to start a test.
Notice here that we're
running these eight tests
with just one single click.
Two orientations, four
different device labs,
is basically the eight tests.
And then the test
is about to start.
I'm not going to wait
for that test to finish.
It usually takes
10 minutes or so,
because the crawler tries
to crawl as much as possible
in the app.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go straight ahead
to one of the test results.
So this is one of the
results on a Nexus
5 running on API level 22.
And again, I was able to
see that exact same crash
that I saw in my crash
reporting console.
But then what I can do
is look at the logs.
So I can see exactly the
logs on the device leading up
to the crash.
I can see some screenshots.
And this is super
cool, because you
notice that these screenshots
were obtained for me without me
having to do anything.
All I really added is just
my app, and that's it.
And I got all these screenshots
for free from within the app.
And then if you
notice here, this
is actually the part where the
cool new feature was clicked
and that the crashes happened.
And then what we can also
look at is the Activity Map.
So the Activity Map here is
a description of every step
that the crawler has taken.
And you can see here this is
the main screen of the app.
And then I clicked
on Progressive.
So I started Progressive levels.
The Robo actually, in
effect, finished a level,
which is pretty impressive.
And then it crashed here.
So these are the it went--
it looked like it went here
to the About
[INAUDIBLE], and then it
clicked on the Cool new
Feature and then crashed.
So this is the path leading
all the way up to the crash.
Now that I was able
to reproduce the crash
and understand the exact steps
that a user or the crawler
has taken to find that crash,
I want to go to my code
and try to fix it.
And what I'm going to
do here is I'm just
going to go to
that About Activity
now that I know that
it's the right place.
And I will see here that
someone added this line.
If the version is more than
Lollipop, throw an exception.
So it seems that maybe
somebody put an Easter egg
or something in demo app.
And this is where the
exception is happening.
So what I'm going to do here
is just comment out this line.
And this should prevent the
crash from happening again.
And then what I want to do,
more importantly, beside fixing
the issue is making
sure that from now on,
this issue actually never
happens in the future.
And this is where we want
to create a test case that
covers this [INAUDIBLE].
Even though the Robo
was actually successful
in finding that crash,
sometimes in our app,
there is a certain
flow that you want
to make sure that it always
works no matter what.
We always need to cover it
with an instrumentation test.
For example, if you're
testing a checkout flow,
this is the most important
flow in your business.
So you want to make sure it
works well no matter what.
So this is why you always want
to cover it with a test case
to make sure that from now on,
every code change that happens
in my app runs this test
and this test basically
covers that change,
and it doesn't break.
So what I'm going to do now is
I want to create that test case.
And to do that, I need to
learn Espresso and spend
five hours studying--
I'm kidding.
All I'm going to do
here is just go to Run
and Record the Espresso test.
So what we can do here is
just record the Espresso test.
And I have the emulator up
and running right now here.
So I'm just going
to record the test.
And the way I'm going
to record the test
is just basically by using
my app, nothing else.
So right now, the
app is being built.
It's going to take
20 seconds or so.
And then it's going to start
on that emulator screen.
And then everything that I do
on that screen, every click
that I do is going to be record.
And at the end of it, I'm
going to see a fully reusable
Espresso test script that I can
run on every code change moving
forward.
So this is the app.
And it seems that the crawler
has clicked on Progressive
or Quick Play, so I'm just going
to click on Quick Play here.
So if you notice here when
I click on Quick Play,
it actually was captured.
So the event was captured here.
And it's showing up in
the recorder screen.
And then I'm going
to keep going.
So maybe I can click
here on the purple thing.
Or maybe not.
[INAUDIBLE] go here
on the Menu page.
And it tells you here that
we select more options.
And then after we
select more options,
we can go to the
Info, which is where
the About Activity triggers.
And then I'm going to
click on Cool New Feature.
So that's it.
That's all the steps we
need leading up to a crash
that I want to cover
with a test case.
And one thing we can do also
with that is add an assertion.
And this is really cool.
When we're testing
something, we want
to make sure that this thing is
functionally correct on every--
[INAUDIBLE] so that
moving forward,
I just check and make sure
that the screen's correct.
So I'm going to try adding
an assertion right now.
Adding an assertion will grab
a snapshot from the screen.
And then it tells
you your stats.
And one thing I can say, for
example, is this your stats?
I just want to make sure
that the text is actually
your stats.
So very simple assertion here.
I'm going to save it.
And with that, I can
complete the recording.
It even suggests a name for you.
Like here's how you
want to name that test.
And you can save the test.
So look what happened here.
This is actually super cool.
This is a functional
Android Espresso test
case that was created for us
without us developers having
to learn anything or write
a single line of code.
And it's a fully functional
Espresso test script
that we can then run.
We can actually try running
it right now, if you want.
Let's do that.
So just going to run it
on the emulator first.
So on the emulator, you
can see it playing here.
Magic.
And it passed.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, thank you.
Now, the second part
is actually-- let's try
to run it on Firebase Test Lab.
So let's take this one that
we recorded on an API level 21
emulator and run the same
test on hundreds of devices.
So I can go here and on
the same screen that I
used to run the test
on the emulator,
I can go to cloud testing.
And then here, what I can see is
there is a configuration that I
created called chinaddd demo,
which has three devices,
two platforms, one locale,
and two orientation's.
By the way, I'm going to run
this test right now first.
And then yeah, let's see.
Yeah, so this is going
to run 12 test for me.
I ran this test once
in the past as well,
so I'm just going to
show you the results.
And when I ran this test, I
actually didn't fix the bug.
I'll just fix the bug right now.
But when I ran the
test, it was supposed
to actually work
correctly on API levels 21
but fail on API levels 22.
And this is exactly
what happened here.
So if you notice here
the Nexus 5 API level 19,
but that's actually
past successful.
Because when I click on the Cool
New Feature, nothing happens.
But then on API levels 22 and
more, the test actually fails.
So this is a reminder for us
to make sure that we always
test our app on
devices that cover
many of our realistic scenarios
and many of our users' devices
that we have.
We can always go to the Play
Store or our analytics data
to understand which devices
are our users using,
which API levels are
more popular, and so on.
So that's it with the demo.
Now it's time to just
go and publish your app
to Google Play, and that's it.
So can we switch
back to the slide?
So let's recap what we just did.
We woke up one morning with
an alert about a new crash
cluster that was happening,
and we received that alert
from Firebase Crash
Reporting that told us
about this new cluster
of crash that is starting
to occur most recently.
We understood the
impact of that crash
by looking at the Firebase
Crash Reporting console.
It told us how many
users were affected,
it gave us some examples
about their devices,
about the environment
leading up to the crash,
based on data it
got from analytics.
And then we were able
to reproduce that crash
by using Fireplace Test
Lab on one of the devices
that we didn't
have in our closet.
And we were able successfully
reproduce that crash.
Once we reproduced that crash,
we were able to debug it.
We looked at our code and
starting fixing that crack.
And then finally, we
had a fix in place.
But more importantly, when
we were releasing that fix
to our users, we
created a test case
to make sure that
this issue never
appears again for our users, and
we covered it with a test case.
So this is the message I'm
going to leave you with.
App quality is one of the
most important factors
for the success
of your business.
So make sure when
you're solving a bug
or you're looking at a crash,
that this is not just a crash
happening to some users-- this
is revenues that I'm losing.
And there are users that might
never come back to my app.
So app quality is one of the
most important contributors
to the success of your business.
And then the second message
I want to leave you with
is that Firebase
App Quality makes
caring about and closing
these app quality
issues really, really easy.
All you need to do is
build a suite of tests.
And we saw that
you don't even need
to have any coding skills to
write that suite of tests.
You can use the Robo, or you can
record your own instrumentation
test with the Espresso
Test Recorder.
And test continuously.
Make sure that you trigger
these test cases on every change
you make in your app.
Every new code change has
to trigger these test cases,
and this will allow you to move
a lot faster and iterate faster
on your app.
And also will reduce the
amount of bugs and crashes
in your app.
And you want to run these tests
on so many different devices,
like the ones that
your users actually do.
And then finally, just
monitor production for crashes
and reactively engage
with these crashes
to make sure that you close them
in a timely manner and very,
very quickly.
And that's it.
Thank you so much.
Again, this is my gchat
account, so feel free to add me.
And yeah, if you have any
questions, let me know.